tout y est ou presque jusque dans les
moindres détails
les membres du groupe de conservation de
la mémoire 1944 sont les artisans de
cette reconstitution d'un camp militaire
américain
c'est leur façon de rendre hommage aux
combattants de la seconde guerre
mondiale
l'intérêt c'est de celle devoir de
mémoire c'est à dire que on met en
situation pour montrer aux gens comment
c'était à l'époque pour leur permettre
peut-être d'appréhender un peu plus
cette période là qui qui a tendance de
plus en plus à s'effacer dans les
mémoires donner à voir mais aussi
expliquer ces collectionneurs passionnés
prennent plaisir à parler avec ceux qui
s'intéressent aux objets qu'ils exposent
toutes les personnes qu'on a pu
rencontrer ici comme plein de petites
anecdotes qu'on pouvait même pas
imaginer ils nous font revivre vraiment
les choses comme c'était à l'époque
c'est vraiment très fort
on voit beaucoup de choses à l'école
quand on est jeune mais enfin je trouve
que quand même canton quand on voit les
choses en vrai quand on les vit c'est
quand même on retient encore mieux puis
ce encore plus intéressante évocation de
la vie en temps de guerre
en marge du camp l'association a
reconstitué aussi une classe comme il en
existait autrefois afin de capter
l'attention des plus jeunes mais pas
seulement
[Musique]
j'estime que la population locale les
civils ont beaucoup souffert de cette
guerre et que l'on parle souvent des
militaires et je trouvais que c'était
important aussi de rendre hommage aux
civils qui ont vécu cette guerre sans
être des militaires à côté de l'école
une épicerie militaire américaine
collection personnelle d'un franco
américain une collection que son frère
qui vit à new york a découvert avec
beaucoup d'émotion s'étonnant de voir le
mal qu'il se donne pour réunir toutes
ces choses et les montrer à tout le
monde
vous voyez c'est quelque chose de
spécial de faire revivre l'histoire mme
bak et moi mais tu es comme ça mais j'ai
l'impression d'être revenu dans cette
époque
dimanche les véhicules de l'association
rejoueront l'arrivée des libérateurs et
le camp sera levé à 18 heures